(dulcet music)
(audience cheers)
- [Andrew] Josh is a dancer.
- [Josh] I'm.
- [Kelly] Dancing feels good.
- Dancing feels so nice.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Andrew] We're here in person with you.
- I know.
- And welcome to New York.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- How do you like it?
- [Kelly] I love it. My
hands are cold, I'm sorry.
- Well, 'cause you're in New York, now.
- [Kelly] It is, I know.
- It's cold in New York.
- I love it though. The
layering, the fall weather.
- [Andrew] Yeah, it's beautiful.
- [Josh] It's a good time of year.
- Yeah, I'm so excited
to have you both here.
- [Andrew] Thank you.
- I'm excited you're having us here.
Andrew didn't wanna do it.
And I was like, we have to.
(all laugh)
- I pissed him off in the Zoom.
(Andrew and Josh laugh)
So like, who chose to do the
kid photos on the Playbill.
I love that.
- We, did it together.
- [Andrew] We did it together,
'cause we were talking.
- [Kelly] Because the whole
thing is about dreams, right?
It's about, yeah. Dreams.
- [Andrew] Can you guys
guess which one is which?
(audience laughs)
Well no, we were talking about
the, you know, first of all,
we were asked to pick
headshots for the playbill,
which I don't know about you,
but I hate picking pictures.
- Oh my gosh. I got in
the wrong line of work.
I hate photos.
- Yeah. It's just, I'm like-
So then we were talking about it.
And I was like, we
should use kid pictures.
Because it is about two
guys who have this dream
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Of taking a show to Broadway.
And that's around the age that
we both sort of discovered
that that's what we wanted to do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We wanted to be actors, and
we wanted to be on Broadway.
- [Kelly] You got the bug.
- Yeah.
So we chose those photos.
- I love instead that.
- [Josh] To be fair,
we did those pictures as kids, knowing
that one day they would
be used as headshots
for Gutenberg, the Musical.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- So it was very forward thinking.
- [Andrew] We really thought ahead.
We're long planners.
- We're planners.
- I know, I like that about y'all.
So what you knew, like what hit you?
Like, what did you see, that
you knew you wanted to be
in musical theater, or in
entertainment in general?
- Oh man, you know, I saw Peter Pan,
with Kathy Rigby, when I was
about five years old, on tour.
And I said one day, I'm not
gonna be able to play that part.
But I'd like to play something else.
(audience laughs)
- Very self-aware, at a young age.
- [Andrew] Yeah, you knew what
your limitations were.
- Yeah.
- Well, it took me a second
to find musical theater.
But what I wanted to be first,
was a Solid Gold dancer.
- [Kelly] A Solid Gold dancer?
- Yes. Does anyone remember Solid Gold?
(Josh laughs)
- Oh, I was like, that was very specific.
- It was a variety show, they had dancers.
I wanted to do that. And then I realized
that there's actually a
different job, called an actor.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Where you could do musicals.
And I started watching the Tony Awards.
And then that really,
- I got in trouble as a kid.
'Cause I was a big
performer, even as a child.
So my mom got called
to the school one day.
Because, as a kindergartner,
I would apparently walk into class late.
What kindergartner walks in late.
- So this all tracks.
- This all tracks.
And I would, apparently open the door,
look at my teacher and go, "Hiya Toots."
And they called my mom to the school.
Or I would say, "Hiya
Toots" or "Lucy, I'm home!"
- It was apparently not okay.
- You were a born performer.
- I was a born performer.
- That's amazing. You're
reminding me of my son.
That is so my son, Remy, because-
- He's got a very horrible future.
(Josh laughs)
- No, he's that kind
of entertaining though.
He's a sponge. He watches
something , he loves it.
He just, it comes, he regurgitates it.
Yeah, it's awesome.
- [Josh] It's a curse.
- So wait, so Halloween.
It's not a curse, it's a
blessing. It's a blessing.
It's a 'blurse'. It's both.
So Halloween is coming up.
I know you got kiddos. So, what do y'all-
Do you dress up?
'Cause I know that we had the cute
little photos of your children.
But I also found this one of you.
And I just have a quick
question here, Andrew.
(all laugh)
Like what, I don't know,
that I've ever known a kid
that dresses as the Pope.
- The Pope, yeah.
- You're a very serious kid.
- [Andrew] It was a very Catholic idea.
- [Kelly] Very serious.
- My brother and his family are here,
so he was witness to this.
- What's up?
- Rannells family.
- Hi.
- [Andrew] So yeah, my grandma
Josephine, had this idea
that I was gonna be the Pope.
So she put together that costume.
She got me, and I was the Pope.
And my little sister,
Natalie, was an angel.
But it's still like, hands down, I'm 45.
That's my best Halloween costume.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love you.
- It's the pope, it
peaked at Fourth grade.
- Can you imagine trick or treat?
I've just never seen a
kid dressed as a Pope.
- As the Pope. I was very popular.
- [Kelly] It's especially like Tony Stark.
(Josh laughs)
- I was very popular, people
took a lot of pictures of me.
It was like, yeah, I felt-
- [Kelly] You were a hit.
- I was a hit.
- [Kelly] Okay, well I have
to pull this one up, too.
- Oh,
- [Andrew] Josh, please.
- This was last year,
and this was incredible.
- [Josh] Yes.
- [Kelly] This is incredible.
(audience cheers)
- [Josh] I mean,
- [Kelly] Flotsam and jetsam.
- What's really complicated,
what's really complicated
about this picture is,
I was also trying to be the Pope.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Josh] It is tricky.
- They're layers.
- Something went very wrong.
- [Andrew] Someone led you astray, Joshua.
- No, I lost a bet with my
daughters. I lost a bet.
They said if you lose this bet,
you have to be Ursula, for Halloween.
And so I ended up being
Ursula for Halloween.
- [Kelly] Please tell me you walked around
trick-or-treating with them,
singing 'Poor unfortunate Souls'.
- [Josh] Oh, a hundred percent.
- Okay.
You would've let me down.
- Oh yeah.
- Do you like to dress up?
- I love to dress up.
- Right.
- I love a theme. I don't
even wanna go to a party
unless it's themed.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Like why, you're just gonna
hang out, and be yourself.
That's boring.
- [Andrew] You don't
like to go to any parties
unless you're themed, or just Halloween?
I'm gonna, let's be real.
- I'm sorry, I can't attend your wedding
unless everybody's
dressed up as a character.
- Wait, I did throw a themed
party, one time though.
And Enrique Iglesias showed up and-
- [Andrew] No,
- Because we had the same
manager at the time.
I don't hang out with
famous people, I'm not cool.
But he showed up, and
he wasn't in costume.
And at that point I'd had a lot to drink.
And so I was very bold, and walked up
and was like, get out,
you don't have a costume.
(Josh laughs)
- I was like, you have to
wear a costume to be here.
And I was like, I'm just kidding.
But kind of get out. I'm sorry.
- Also, get a costume.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I can't rap. It
says rap, and there's nothing.
But I will make (beep) up.
- [Andrew] There's nothing to rap.
- Okay, I was like, it says rap.
And I was like, I dunno if you've noticed-
- You can rap.
You can totally rap.
- [Kelly] I can not rap.
- Hi, we'll be back after this break.
(all laugh)
- So I'm not just saying this.
I've literally heard so
much, 'cause everybody here
also talks about shows, right.
Nonstop, which I love.
But everybody is talking
about Gutenberg, the musical.
So where did this come from?
- [Josh] That's your show.
- [Andrew] You're in it too, look Josh.
- [Josh] That's us.
- [Andrew] That's us.
- You are about, two men
in one dream. No chance.
I like it.
Says it all, right there.
- [Josh] That's it, that's
all you need to know.
- So what do people
need to know, coming in?
- Hmm.
- [Kelly] Or do you want them to know?
- Well, we're in it. Well
no, so it's about two guys,
named Bud and Doug.
Who have decided, they're sort of new fans
of musical theater.
They wanna write a musical,
they wanna write a hit musical.
So they decide that a historical musical,
- [Josh] Can I just say,
you're doing great right now.
- Thank you very much.
A historical musical.
Those do well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So they pick, to write a
musical about Johann Gutenberg,
the inventor of the printing press.
'Cause isn't that like a fun, sexy idea?
(audience laughs)
- I have a quicker pitch, which is,
it's the Hamilton of our generation.
- No.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- I've explained this to Josh, many times.
Hamilton, is the Hamilton
of our generation.
- Hamilton.
- It's the other Hamilton
of our generation.
- [Kelly] It's the other one.
- No, we're having the best time.
- Yes.
- Rannells and I, the last
time I was on Broadway
was over a decade ago.
I've been, when we did
Book of Mormon together.
And I've been wanting to come back.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] So good.
- And I've been wanting to come back,
and I only really wanted
to come back with him.
'Cause he's the only person
who would perform with me.
- [Andrew] Well, work with you.
- And so,
- And finally the
restraining orders ran out.
- Yeah, they lifted it.
- [Andrew] So then I was able
to get back on stage.
- So physically, we could
work together again.
- Legally,
- But it's been, you know,
the world needs some laughter right now.
It's a sad time in the world.
And it's been really refreshing to be able
to provide people with that sense
of just, two hours of escapism.
And we get to be idiots.
And we play, each of us
plays about 20 characters.
We have 150 hats, that
we wear in this show.
- Literal hats.
- I hear that it's chaos
backstage, is this true?
I can imagine.
- [Josh] Yes, it is chaos.
- This is a strange show,
because we're on stage the entire time.
Like, once Josh and I go out there.
- Oh, so there's no break.
What if you have to pee?
- We do it on stage.
- [Andrew] Well, there's an interval.
- Okay.
- [Andrew] Josh, where's
the diaper? Well actually,
- By the way, I wear a
man diaper in the show.
- Would you like to explain this?
- [Josh] I wanna tell you
guys, when we first started
doing the show, I had my shirt tucked in.
And every time I danced, it would come up.
- It would come up.
- And you would just
see too much of my body.
(audience laugh)
And so, they said to me,
we have to button you
into your pants.
(audience laughs)
- Now, the technical term
for this, is a crotch strap.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But the untechnical term
for it, is a pain in the ass.
- Okay.
- 'Cause I have to
basically wear this diaper
that I'm fastened into.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Andrew] So, he's wearing a onesie.
- And sometimes, you know, before a show
you need to go number two, or four.
- Joshua.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Josh] We all get it, it's okay.
- You wanna feel lighter?
- [Josh] This is a safe space.
- Yeah, I feel comfortable.
(audience applauds)
- In order to do what I
need to do, as a human,
I have to have a grown
man, unbuttoned 20 buttons.
- I don't help with this.
- No, but Andrew watches.
- I do watch it, like this.
(Kelly laughs)
- I watch like that.
- So wait, have you had a moment?
'Cause I've had moments on tour,
where I'm on stage, and I'm like,
- I had a moment during Book of Mormon
where I felt my stomach drop.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And I was like,
- And the sweat, the one bead of sweat.
- Oh, the sweat started coming,
and the audience was like,
why does that character
look so uncomfortable?
(audience laughs)
- [Andrew] You made it through.
- Well, I literally
remember, I was timing.
I had a minute and a half.
There was a bathroom
right next to- this is not
where I wanted this to go.
- [Andrew] No, this has
really taking a turn.
- [Kelly] I'm just
saying, you were already
wearing a diaper.
- This is my fault, and I
apologize to everyone watching.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- We'll just, but the diaper is part
of the glamour of Broadway.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- You've been friends for so long now.
(audience laughs)
You tolerate each other,
you've tolerated each other
for at least a decade.
- [Andrew] Sure, sure.
- So wait, are there times, because it is
a hard industry, and I think
everybody always thinks
we're all barbecuing
together, all the time.
But sometimes you don't, like I don't have
a lot of friends that are like,
- No, sometimes we saute together.
- [Kelly] So wait, do you
have those times though?
It seems like that kind of friendship
that you can connect, when
you're like, man, this is hard.
Like when you're being serious.
- Well, we went, you know,
doing the Book of Mormon together.
Obviously we could not
have predicted that show
would've been as successful as it was.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Yeah, I mean,
- I thought it was gonna
close within three weeks.
- Yeah, we were sort of
all nervous about it.
- Wow, you have no pulse on the people.
- [Josh] By the way, I thought Frozen
was gonna be a bomb, too.
I was like, what do I know.
- Josh, you really, yeah,
you've got your finger
on the pulse.
But we got to go through that
whole experience together.
We went through the Tony Awards together.
We both moved back to
Los Angeles together.
We both had TV shows together.
They both got canceled together.
(Josh laughs)
We gotta go through all of it.
- [Kelly] Best of friends.
You do everything together.
- And you know, I could
look at Josh, and be like,
oh, you know exactly what I
am going through right now.
- Which is hard to describe to people.
- Which is very rare.
- Yeah, it is.
And we really- now, you know,
over a decade into this relationship,
we know when the other person needs space
from everybody encroaching on us.
So it's like,
- Sometimes I need a snack.
- Sometimes he needs,
sometimes he gets hangry.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm like, Vesuvius
is about to burst.
I need to protect the citizens of Pompeii.
I need to protect all the
citizens of Pompeii right now.
- Yeah.
- Give Andrew five minutes.
- He needs a cracker.
- Yes, Shelby needs his juice.
- But vice versa, we both sort of,
- We know.
- We protect each other,
in a way that only comes
with time, and barbecuing together.
(audience laughs)
- [Andrew] We need to do that.
- We've never done that.
- We need to do that.
- [Kelly] Oh, look at this.
Moments are being made.
- Three of us, are gonna barbecue.
- [Kelly] I love barbecue.
Don't invite me. Yeah,
- [Josh] We're gonna do it.
- [Andrew] It'll be a themed barbecue
- Themed, I won't show up, unless a theme.
- We'll have a theme party.
- Yeah.
- We'll come back for a cooking segment.
- We all have to dress up
like toy story characters.
(Andrew and Josh laugh)